it was reaction Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy I'm not giving up my my gas
stove I was actually a cook in a
restaurant when I was younger Senator
and you can't cook in a restaurant
without a gas stove that I know of
well
um
famously President Lincoln
Had A Team of Rivals
sometimes I think President Biden has a
team of morons
I don't mean to be unfair oh that's fair
many of many of President Biden's
appointees are very smart
but uh so was the Unabomber my point is
that uh they may be smart but they they
don't have any sense
for example
um
Secretary of Buddha Jag
we learned this week took a uh a carbon
spewing private plane to New York City
for a few hours to do a radio interview
now I like the secretary but less than
30 days ago his Department
told the states that they ought to make
Building New Roads the lowest possible
priority because of climate change
now not everybody has a private jet most
people need to drive a car
and I know life is full of
contradictions but where I come from we
call that hypocrisy I'm willing to work
with President Biden and and the
secretary on our environment but uh if
you're going to be a brave Eco Warrior
you need to be consistent
you mentioned the ban
yes sir I was just going to say Sean you
mentioned the ban on gas stoves by
President Biden I want you to consider
the context in which this decision was
made
something's very wrong in our country
and most Americans know it
the borders wide open crimes way up our
national debt is greater than a national
output
um if inflation keeps going up the
Powerball jackpot's going to be a pound
of hamburger
uh 70 percent of the American people say
the country is headed in the wrong
direction
and the bite Administration is worried
about about gas stoves
if if this Administration is
consistently demonstrated a blind spot
about the lives and concerns of ordinary
Americans and if I were president and my
number one accomplishment was a decline
in the standard of living for most
Americans I wouldn't be worried about
gas stoves
well they also I don't know if you heard
about this they want to get rid of
fluorescent light bulbs I like my
fluorescent light bulbs just like I like
my gas stove Center I like to keep it
and by the way if they ban it who's
going to pay for all the new stoves for
people that can't afford them
well let me make one more plea to
President Biden
um
stop listening to the berserk wing of
your party
worry about and try to do something
about
the things that moms and dads worry
about
when they can lie down to sleep at night
and can't and the rest of it will take
care of itself
I think you'd be a better president
hands down we love having you Senator
John Kennedy thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else